[Music]
come with me
and let's build the future
together
[Music]
what do you care about
remember your past
make a business out of that feeling
what do you think when i say workspace
cubicles
ugly furniture
bad fluorescent lighting
death
exactly
the future of work looks different we're
selling an experience
[Music]
we
we need a name we
we live we dream
we work
who is in a fight the smart guy
or the crazy guy
are you crazy enough i may be i may be
is adam for real i wouldn't be with him
if he wasn't the wife she works there
she helps him manifest things we are on
track to lose 400 million this year
i think this enough adam
we're actually trapped you have to make
them see see what you're super northern
you're afraid that he outshines you can
i get a single battle
are you a maverick or a muse amuse tell
me about your goals i want to be in
vanity fair
vanity fair's not for muses
then i want to change my answer
i wanted you to meet legendary adam
newman and his wife chief friending
officer
we lease office space then we act like
we're changing the world they're turning
on you you're going to sink the ship
[Music]
that's 1.9 billion losses nothing is
more important
than us i have a responsibility to think
bigger i'm a golden goose land golden
eggs you couldn't do this without me
we do this together we can change
everything
[Music]
you